nous sommes à l'ouest de l'amérique du
nord il y à 65 millions d'années
tout un monde va disparaître un
astéroïde de 10 km de diamètre entre en
collision avec la terre
des nuages de poussières masquant la
lumière du soleil
des milliers d'espèces périssent les
dinosaures ne s'en relèveront pas et les
mammifères hérite de la terre c'est une
théorie passionnante mais les
scientifiques ne sont toujours pas
d'accord sur la cause de la disparition
des dinosaures
les dinosaures ont peuplé tous les
continents
certains des plus connus comme le
tricératops et le tyrannosaurus rex
en fait partie de l'arrière-garde à
l'époque du crétacé
à la fin du crétacé il y à 65 millions
d'années les dinosaures disparus
depuis plus de dix ans que johansson et
son équipe du musée d'histoire naturelle
de denver fouille les étendues
désertiques du dakota du nord
ils cherchent des indices sur l'un des
plus grands mystères de la science
l'étude de l'extinction des dinosaures
est très compliqué on assez énormes
animaux qui vivaient sur la terre il y à
150 millions d'années puis ils ont
disparu il ya 65 millions d'années
c'est très difficile de trouver le
coupable d'un crime vieux de 65 millions
d'années
couvrant des centaines de kilomètres
carrés le long de la rivière de l'école
mais j'aurai cette région du dakota est
l'un des endroits sur terre où on a le
plus de chances de percer le mystère
on les trouve des fossiles bien préservé
qui date de l'époque crucial où les
dinosaures ont disparu
nous
oui c'est la poêle à l'horizon qui
marque l'extinction des dinosaures en
dessous de ce niveau et là bas on trouve
de nombreux fossiles au dessus de ce
niveau dans ces roches et il n'y en a
absolument aucun je maintiens sur le
niveau qui marque l'extinction des
dinosaures
que s'est il passé entre le crétacé
tertiaire qui aurait pu provoquer la
disparition des dinosaures
l'un des indices les plus intéressants
et là à nos pieds dans une couche
d'argile en 1978 l'analyse d'un
échantillon provenant de groupes bio en
italie révéla qu'il était riche en
iridium plutôt rare dans l'écorcé
terrestre
l'irridium est courant dans les
météorites
et l'échantillon italien contenait
trente fois la concentration normale
d'iridium une quantité qui ne pouvaient
provenir que de l'espace
l'argile encerclent le monde de la
nouvelle zélande au dakota du nord
cette argile contient de grosses
quantités d'iridium et il ne semble y
avoir qu'une explication un astéroïde
géant s'est écrasé sur la tête
les rochers se sont pulvérisés en un
nuage de poussière fortement chargées en
iridium qui s'est répandu autour du
monde pour qu'un astéroïde puisse
produire une telle quantité d'iridium il
devait mesurer 10 km de diamètre et
peser un milliard de tonnes
cette théorie du big bang et est très
controversée mais il a paru de plus en
plus évidente qu'un astéroïde géant
s'était écrasé dans la région des
caraïbes
il y à 65 millions d'années on a trouvé
les traces d'un cratère de 200 km de
diamètre dans le nord du yucatan pour
laissé un cratère de cette dimension
l'impact à lui être dix mille fois plus
puissant que si toutes les armes
nucléaires du monde explosé en même
temps
que s'est-il passé après l'explosion
personne ne le sait véritablement une
des théories et qu'elle déclenche à un
gigantesque incendie qui se propagea
dans le monde entier
un chercheur a trouvé de grandes
quantités de carbone dans la couche
d'iridium à la fois au danemark et en
nouvelle-zélande c'est peut être le
signe d'un vaste holocauste certains
scientifiques pensent que l'explosion a
provoqué un raz-de-marée de plus de 500
mètres de haut
d'autres prétendent que la poussière
engendrés par le choc a provoqué des
torrents de pluies acides qui ont tué de
nombreuses espèces de plantes et
d'animaux
d'autres encore pensent que quand
l'astéroïde a explosé des milliards de
tonnes de rochers ont été pulvérisés
libérant de vastes quantités d'anhydride
carbonique dans l'atmosphère
tout ce co2 auraient emprisonné la
chaleur de la terre transformant la
planète en une serre géant
la température s'est élevée par tous à
moins que le choc n'ait provoqué un
hiver nucléaire
dans ce scénario des nuages de poussière
et de fumée ont fait écran à la lumière
du soleil
plongeant la terre dans une obscurité
glace et les plantes ont cessé de
produire de l'oxygène et la vie a
disparu lentement
cette région est aujourd'hui très aride
mais il ya 65 millions d'années avant la
chute de l'astéroïde
elle était recouverte d'une heure
superbe forêt essayez de l'imaginer à la
fin du crétacé avec des dinosaures qui
pèse d'autres qui déambulent à travers
la forêt luxuriante quelques heures
quelques jours quelques - tout au plus
après l'explosion il ne restait plus
rien
on
comme les scientifiques ne sont pas
d'accord sur l'impact de l'astéroïde
ils cherchent des indices dans les
fossiles
ces terres désolées du montana et du
dakota du nord attire les chasseurs de
fossiles qui veulent éclaircir le
mystère de la disparition des dinosaures
johansson cherche aussi des fossiles
mais pas de dinosaures les dinosaures
sont passionnants c'est certain mais on
n'en trouve pas beaucoup et il donne
beaucoup de travail
les fossiles de feuilles raconte des
histoires différentes
elle renseigne sur leur environnement
regardez le monde d'aujourd'hui c'est
une planète verte des plantes poussent
sur toute la surface de la terre les
plantes réagissent à leur environnement
et on apprend beaucoup de choses quand
on les observe plus tard il est évident
que comme il y a beaucoup de feuilles
dans la nature il y a aussi beaucoup de
faux cils on a fait le calcul en se
basant sur une forêt moderne un hectare
produit 22 millions de feuilles par an
observé les feuilles c'est comme ouvrir
une fenêtre sur le crétacé on en apprend
bien plus qu on observant seulement des
animaux
il arrive que les restes de plusieurs
plantes soient préservés sur une seule
roche
des feuilles de nénuphars et d'une
espèce de magnolia peuvent apparaître
côte à côte depuis dix ans johnson a
rassemblé plus de 30000 fossiles de
plantes elles nous donnent des tas de
détails sur leur environnement à
l'époque où le t-rex et le tricératops
se baladait dans le dakota du nord
si on regarde cette feuille par exemple
les bords sont lisses et lapointe
allongée c'est le genre de feuilles
qu'on trouve aujourd'hui dans les forêts
vierges qui reçoivent beaucoup de pluie
et ne souffre pas du froid l'hiver c'est
à dire un endroit bien différent de
celui où nous nous trouvons et qui est
devenue un désert mais il y à 66
millions d'années c'est un sans doute
une forêt tropicale
donc les fossiles de fin et nous
renseigne sur le climat dans lequel elle
poussait c'est ainsi qu'on peut dire que
cette région était humide et jouissait
d'un climat tempéré
on a trouvé des fossiles de pamiers ici
des palmiers près de la frontière du
canada
cela signifie que le climat doit cette
région était plus chaud et plus humide
qu'il ne l'est aujourd'hui
le microscope de johnson a révélé de
nouveaux indices comme du pollen cela
lui a permis d'identifier plus de 100
espèces de plantes du crétacé mais à la
fin de cette époque
un incident s'est produit si l'on en
croit johnson pratiquement 80% des
plantes ont disparu
je suis tout à fait convaincu qu'il y a
eu une catastrophe biologique majeur à
la fin du crétacé et au moment de cette
catastrophe coïncide avec l'impact d'un
astéroïde
alors je crois que c'est lui le coupable
la théorie de l'astéroïde laissent
cependant de nombreux paléontologues
incrédule c'est le cas du chasseur de
fossiles bob barker
il y a une théorie très populaire auprès
des journalistes et des géophysiciens
c'est qu'un astéroïde le poing géant de
dieu a heurté la terre à la fin du
crétacé les résultats à un immense nuage
de poussière à cacher le soleil et
provoquer des pluies acides qui ont tué
tous les dinosaures
c'est stupide une météorite a pu heurter
la terre à l'époque où les dinosaures
disparaissait mais les dinosaures
étaient déjà en voie d'extinction
c'est un mouvement qui était né il ya
déjà 6 millions d'années et si la chute
d'une météorite avait été suffisante
pour tuer les dinosaures
elle aurait exterminé du même coup les
crapauds les tortues et les grenouilles
rien n'est plus délicat qu'une tortue
tropicale elle ne supporte aucun
changement de température
donc si une météorite heure de la terre
soulève un immense nuage de poussière
provoque des pluies acides et un
refroidissement qui va mourir d'abord un
dinosaure de dylan ou une tortue de 1 kg
sera évidemment la tortue et pourtant
elles ne sont pas mortes
les tortues ne se sont pas éteintes à la
fin du crétacé alors la question n'est
pas pourquoi les dinosaures sont ils
morts mais pourquoi les tortues
ont-elles sur v club bakker prend du
recul il s'intéresse aux 150 millions
d'années de présence sur terre des
dinosaures
de nombreuses espèces ont disparu bien
avant la chute de l'astéroïde des
espèces on est et se sont éteintes
pendant toute cette longue période et
pas seulement à la fin
on retrouve toujours la même méthode est
ce qu'on recherche c'est un meurtrier un
meurtrier darwinien qui s'attaque à la
terre et à l'océan
tous les 15 ou 20 millions d'années ils
frappent toujours de la même manière et
des victimes bien déterminée dans
l'écosystème ce sont toujours les mêmes
animaux qui sont ses victimes et les
mêmes qu'on laisse en paix c'est à la
fois effrayant est bizarre d'après
bakker
les problèmes ont commencé au début du
crétacé
le super continent de pangée a continué
à se diviser en plusieurs masses
terrestres
l'amérique du sud l'afrique et l'inde
sont devenus isolé mais l'amérique du
nord et rester unis avec leur asie
des mères peu profondes se sont retirés
permettant aux animaux de se déplacer un
dinosaure pouvait aller du wyoming en
mongolie à travers l'alaska et vice
versa il suffisait à un dinosaure
chinois de traverser le détroit de
béring et le canada pour arriver dans le
royaume chaque dinosaures qui partait
d'ailleurs transporter 20 à 30 maladie à
la fin du jurassique des bandes de terre
reliant encore les différentes masses
des dizaines de dinosaures changer de
lieu en transportant des centaines de
maladies il n'avait aucun moyen d'
arrêter l'hécatombe mondiale des animaux
qui se déplaçait mais il n'existe aucune
preuve à l'appui de cette théorie
stephen gould biologiste à l'université
de harvard soutient celle de l'astéroïde
il suggère une explication simple au
fait que les grands animaux sont plus
vulnérables que les petits en cas de
catastrophe
pourquoi est ce que les dinosaures sont
morts eh bien nous n'en savons rien mais
si vous voulez une hypothèse
je pense que leur énorme tas il n'a pas
été favorable à leur survie en période
de catastrophe
si vous êtes très grand vous ne pouvez
pas être très nombreux et le meilleur
moyen de pouvoir survivre c'est d'être
très nombreux il y a davantage de
chances que quelques-uns en réchappe un
autre problème si vous êtes très grand
c'est qu'il y à peu d'endroits où vous
pouvez vous cacher tandis que les
mammifères qui étaient des créatures
minuscules devait être très nombreux et
savoir comment se mettre à l'abri dans
les deux sens du terme il est possible
que les dinosaures étaient victimes de
leur grande taille mais une nouvelle
étude des fossiles révèle des complices
du crime
quand les dinosaures se sont éteints
d'autres animaux ont survécu une étude
approfondie des fossiles par des vies
date symbole de l'université de san
diego permet d'établir des schémas
intéressant sur les animaux qui ont
survécu et ceux qui ont disparu
quand on étudie le processus de l'esp
action on nage en plein mystère on
trouve cinq groupes qui ont été durement
touchés et les autres à peine les
requins ont été affectés les lézards les
deux groupes de dinosaures et les
marsupiaux et c'est là le noeud du
problème
pourquoi les requins et les dinosaures
ont-ils tellement souffert et pas les
mammifères placentaires dont nous
faisons partie
les dinosaures sont morts mais les
tortues les grenouilles et les
crocodiles ont survécu une période de
froid succédant à la chute de
l'astéroïde était la cause de
l'extinction des dinosaures
les paléontologues ont toujours été
persuadé que les dinosaures ne pouvaient
survivre que dans des climats tropicaux
mais bill clemens de l'université de
californie a trouvé des os de dinosaure
dans le nord de l'alaska où les était
doux du crétacé devait pourtant être
suivi divers sombre et froid voici les
autres qu'on a découvert sur la pente
nord de l'alaska
ce sont les restes de dinosaures pour la
première fois ils nous ont apporté la
preuve que les dinosaures pouvait vivre
à de haute altitude
de nos jours la région côtière au sud de
l'alaska et fraîche et humide à la fin
du crétacé les longues journées d'été et
des une végétation luxuriante a poussé
et ce type de paysage s'étendait
vraisemblablement jusqu'à la pente nord
de petits dinosaures végétarien s'y
trouvait parfaitement bien la jil is
yellow fono par exemple dont le museau
corner pouvait s'attaquer aux branches
et qui avaient des papes de gazelle
bill clément a trouvé beaucoup de leur
zoo tout au nord de l'alaska
d autres comme cela nous montre que des
dinosaures vivaient dans cet
environnement sombre et froid il y à 65
millions d'années
si on étudie ces spécimens on s'aperçoit
qu'il y à là toutes les tailles des
bébés dinosaures et de vieux adultes
la découverte la plus étonnante était la
grande quantité d'eau de jeunes animaux
la vieille théorie voulait que les
dinosaures à y passer l'été en alaska
pour paître et reviennent dans le sud au
moment de l'hiver mais comme le souligne
clemens des animaux aussi jeunes
n'auraient jamais survécu à ce périple
de 15 100 km alors vivait-il toute
l'année en alaska
récemment on l'a découvert plusieurs
autres espèces de dinosaures en
australie il y à 125 millions d'années
l'hiver australien était glaciale les
dinosaures se serait-il adaptés au froid
dans ce cas il aurait pu survivre après
la chute de l'astéroïde et ce sont les
fragiles tortue qui aurait dû
disparaître mais c'est le contraire qui
s'est produit les dinosaures ont disparu
tandis que les tortues et les crocodiles
ont survécu
cela signifie que le mystère de
l'extinction ne serait liée ni au froid
ni à l'obscurité
clemens crois qu'un refroidissement
progressif étalé sur des millions
d'années a fait naître lentement une
espèce de pression subtile qui a poussé
les dinosaures vers l'extinction il
établi une analogie avec le monde
végétal d'aujourd'hui dans les déserts
américains du sud ouest les cactus
tolère de grands écarts de température
entre le jour et la nuit
mais dans les montagnes de l'arizona il
y à une altitude au dessus de laquelle
ils cessent de pousser clemons prétend
que c'était pareil pour les dinosaures
ils pouvaient s'adapter à certains
changements de température mais il y
avait des limites
la théorie de l'astéroïde fait périr les
dinosaures dans le froid et l'obscurité
en quelques jours ou quelques semaines
mais l'étude des fossiles d'eau et de
plantes fait apparaître cette
explication comme beaucoup trop
simpliste
la théorie de la météorite est
extrêmement populaire parce qu'elle est
parfaite pour les couvertures de
magazines time magazine nous a montré
cette merveilleuse peinture de
tyrannosaurus rex paniquer à l'instant
où cette grosse boule de feu se dirige
vers lui
c'est du grand art c'est du beau cinéma
mais c'est nul au point de vue
scientifique
on laisse de côté le profil de la
victime il ne faut pas oublier qu'on
cherche un assassin récidiviste
quelqu'un qui tue au coeur de
l'écosystème en utilisant toujours la
même méthode et en ignorant les
grenouilles à des tortues la théorie de
la météorite laisse de côté ce fait
capital difficile de dire ce qui est le
plus sensationnel un assassin
récidivistes ou un astéroïde géant mais
lien fait que personne ne peut nier les
dinosaures sont tous morts la théorie de
l'astéroïde a été soutenue par de
nombreux scientifiques 14 ans ont passé
depuis la découverte d'iridium en italie
et une incroyable quantité de
renseignements a pu être rassemblés
il concerne à la fois les impacts
d'astéroïdes la vie des plantes et des
animaux à la fin du crétacé et au début
du tertiaire avec tout le tapage fait
autour de la comète qui a percuté
jupiter on commence à réaliser que des
impacts d'astéroïdes ou le connaître ne
sont pas des choses impossibles ni rare
dans notre système solaire et rien ne
permet de nier que des impacts de
planètes ou d'astéroïdes ait pu
influencer l'évolution de la vie sur la
terre on ne saura peut-être jamais si
les dinosaures sont morts victimes
d'épidémie diverses ou si la découverte
d'iridium indique bien que c'est un
changement de climat qui les a tués mais
une chose est certaine sans cette
extinction la vie sur la terre aurait
pris une tournure bien différente
comme nous le dit steven gold il semble
très probable que si nous sommes ici
aujourd'hui c'est qu'une espèce de
loterie on a décidé ainsi
les dinosaures qui avait dominé si
longtemps les manifs
ont tous été victimes d'un fléau contre
lequel de toute évidence il n'avait
aucun moyen de se protéger
le hasard a donc joué un grand rôle dans
l'histoire de la vie on peut dire que si
nous sommes là c'est grâce à
l'extinction des dinosaures
quels cas difficile à résoudre pour un
détective il y a plusieurs coupables
possibles un lent changement de climat
une vague d'épidémie un astéroïde et les
indices susceptibles de l'éclairer ont
65 millions d'années
le mystère de l'extinction des
dinosaures ne sera peut-être jamais
éclaircies
e